you talk about the devil's hell though
and make sure that people know that the
devil cell is a reference to your
butthole that's right make sure you say
uh sorry I'm gonna order in a moment I'm
sorry um I'll have a water I'm talking
about my anus I call
[Music]
bad things that any of your exes have
done to you you look like you're a
little bit spiky and full of rage any
like skin issues that you have and if
you don't believe in evolution keep it
yours there's nothing more romantic than
sharing a salad I'll order for the lady
always if you're a guy always order for
the woman women love that yes you're a
man on a first date make sure you sort
of tell her what she's like yeah make
sure to show her you through her yeah
you're gonna have the Caesar salad and
I'm gonna feed you those anchovies right
I think if I was on a first date and a
man was checking his phone at the table
I would think that he kind of doesn't
like know what's up I think you want to
have a phone handy so you can show other
person with your prior convictions
[Music]
I mean read the room yeah read the room
but I always like to hug you know unless
they're like you don't like them then
you should handshake and then they'll
know this is over what I'll usually say
is I go can I hug your lips with my
tongue and they're confused by that and
but I've already run out of the room
I'm so sorry having such a bad time I
I'm so sorry I just realized no random
but I'm having such a bad time your
personality is just absolutely the
opposite of what I was hoping for and I
am I am so sorry that's so weird but I
have to go
well probably Frank's redhot sir
you gotta bring the cheese in your purse
you gotta bring a warm cheese I like to
eat a lot of a cheese before a date and
so that there's a real gurgle in my
stomach oh great
I had like a lady
split it banana 2014 if it's a male and
a female on a date I think the guy pays
and says you owe me
I know it's not 2014 she's doing a joke
we all know it's 2015